okay so hi everyone and my name is
Sheila
and I currently finished my work at blue
vine as Ally data scientist and now I'm
starting to work at Intuit both
companies are great both are hiring so
you're welcome to to approach me for any
of them or both and I came here today to
continually Ron's talk about imbalance
data set and talk a little bit about not
about how you handle it with modeling
part but how you handle the imbalance in
the data in evaluating your model
because what kind of metrics do you
usually use for evaluating your model
example yeah okay something else
f1 okay anything else accuracy yeah
precision balance accuracy okay okay
okay so we're gonna talk today about
what is imbalance data sight of course
most of you know that and why won't you
you don't want to use accuracy for an
imbalance data set as you most of you
probably know now if you do use other
metrics which are better like precision
and recall and ROC metrics which are
better in which cases because sometimes
precision and recall are not the best
also for balanced data set and sometimes
the ROC metrics are not that good and we
will just talk about the cases where you
want to use which and and that it will
gonna see it in a few examples and then
we connect conclude so in balance data
set as you all know it has many
application fraud detection anomaly
detection for example in bluevine we
want to approve deals automatically for
loans for small businesses so for
example most of the deals and we get our
good deals and we want to approve them
automatically but the deals which are
not good or we're not sure about then we
don't want to approve automatically and
then we give them to an analyst
vision so in this case scenario most of
the deals are good they are the
positiveness and they are the majority
but if we will approve all the deals
then it would be very bad because we
will approve also the deals which are
bad so it's important for us to be
accurate on the deals we approve it the
precision is very important for us but
for example if we have a fraud a model
we want to detect fraud so further
usually a small a part of the population
because fraudulent deals are a using not
many so in this case the precision is
important but also and more important is
the recall because we don't want to miss
a fraud case so we also have to always
think about what is our business metric
we want to optimize so these are many is
two different cases were in one case
with the majority class is the positive
class America the other case the
minority class is the positive class ok
so why not accuracy it's very easy of
course because if you have imbalance
that is that like 90% 10% if the model
is naive model and hits always saying
the majority class then it will have 90%
accuracy right it is great but it is a
really bad model so not accuracy now
precision Enrico small recap what is
precision precision is the probability
that out of the samples we said there
are positive we are actually correct in
these samples ok it is the green part
versus all the circle here the circle is
all the samples we say that are positive
the left part is all the positive
samples and the right part is all the
negative samples now what is the Rico is
how many of the positive did we catch
out of our data some kind of coverage
metric and now what is the ROC ROC is a
curve as you all know also there is a
curve for precision Rico of course and
every point in the ROC curve stands for
a different
we choose for our model most of the
models produce probabilities and we want
to choose which threshold a to use so we
use it we try to find the optimal point
for us on the rocker now each point
stands for a different threshold and
each point has a different true positive
rate and false positive rate as you all
know now today we're going to focus just
on one point what is true positive rate
and false positive rate the whole curve
is not interesting now and so what is
the true positive rate it is exactly the
recall how many good samples did we
catch and what is the false positive
rate
is the probability of foster home how
many false positives we have divided by
the total number of negatives we have
okay so it looks similar to precision
and Rico but actually it's not
so and what is the difference and
someone tell me what is the difference
mean the ROC metrics and the precision
and recall no but I said a threshold now
when I look at the true positive right
and the false positive rate okay so I
will help you the difference is that
false positive rates is not precision
because true positive rate is recalled
okay so this is the different false
positive rate versus precision now what
is exactly the difference this is
precision the green is a half part and
they divided by the circle and this is
the false positive rate and here we have
the false positives in the denominator
and here we have the true negatives in
the denominator denominator now how does
this affect our metrics for different
data scenarios let us see okay so what I
did in order for us to understand better
I try to simulate with this simple
diagram from Wikipedia how
imbalance data set look like for these
metrics for example if we have a
majority of negative samples for example
in the fraud example then the gray part
is really big because most of our data
is negatives it's not fraud right so in
this case and for a majority of negative
samples if the true negatives is sorry
if the false positives is very small I'm
sorry if the false positives is about
the same the same size as all the
positives it's not very dominant because
we have all these negatives in the
denominator okay so we will get a very
low false positive right in this case
when we have majority negative samples
even if we have a lot of false positives
comparing to the number of positives we
have in the data now on the other side
if we have majority of positive samples
for example if we have many good deals
we want to approve and only a few bad
deals we want to reject and then the
left side the part of the positives will
be very big now we will have a lot of
true positives because we have a lot of
a positive so it's easy to detect these
and the precision would look very skewed
because we will have a lot of true
positives and the false positives would
have a very small impact on the a on
this a ratio okay so even if we have a
little false if we have a lot of false
positives comparing to the number of a
would not feel it much with the
precision because it would still be high
now if that wasn't clear we would see a
couple examples for this now first
example is a majority of positive
samples
in this case we have a model which
predicts all the samples as positive a
very bad model right because it doesn't
detect negative samples at all now what
we see here here I calculated the best
basic matrix and we say that the
precision is 90% which is really high
and the reco is 100% it's really good
right and the true positive rate is 100%
is exactly the reco but the false
positive rate is 100% this reflects that
the model is actually not a good model
so in this case we see that the true
positive rate and false positive rate is
more suitable to reflect the actual
performance of this model now we take
the same example but switch the label
that both metrics are the same so it has
meaning which is very classic
now I will skip this example okay sorry
um and I will just well just keep to the
last example because I don't have time
um so if I have a majority of negative
samples and a minority of positive
samples if we classify all the samples
is positive and but only one is really
positive again a very bad model and in
this case we see that true positive and
false positives I'm sorry these are all
the metrics we calculate the precision
in this case is very low the recall is
very high so this reflects good that the
model is actually not good but the true
positive rate is the rook the recall
again and the false positive rate
actually not that high so it doesn't say
that the model is that bad so in this
case the precision is low and the false
positive rate is not high which means
that a precision recall reflects the
model performance much better in this
case
so a I don't have time to conclude but
you can read their conclusions at home
but just take just take these two tips a
from its life just think which will be
the better metrics and guide yourself
with which one is the majority class the
positive or the negatives and maybe you
can switch them hey hi everyone my name
is cha ha I'm a research intern at spark
Beyond and also pursuing my master at
the computer science department at the
Technion and my talk today will be about
how we can better derive confidence in
our regression models and how can we
have more insights about the problem we
have every day possibly encouraging a
better decision-making
so to start let let's just recap what we
usually do in in regression models and
what quantile regression is okay so
usually in regression model we wanted
the average relationship between set of
features X and an outcome variable Y
based on the conditional mean function
for example you can think about trying
to estimate the arrival time from Haifa
to Tel Aviv based on some data set of
observation and and your model will come
into conclusion and into a prediction of
one hour while this approximation mind
sounds reasonable for the mean function
if I plant my travel to Tel Aviv today
according to this prediction there is
significant probability I would be late
one tile regression aims at providing
much more information on the
distribution of Y given X to be more
concrete let's for any quantile between
0 & 1 we want to be able to predict a
value V such that with probability Q our
estimation will be above the real value
okay with such modeling we can come we
can predict for example the devii 95%
where the semantics for this prediction
is that I'm confidence with 95% that I
will arrive on time to PI data if I
follow this prediction there are many
many motivations for why we need
quantile regression I'll give you just a
taste so
as I started showing on the previous
slide sometimes this information is
quite essential I'm not confident enough
in the in the mean function
approximation to take actions I want to
know about probabilities and about
outcomes sometime I'm more interested in
high probability events sometimes I want
to know about rare events I don't know
crisis I want to prepare myself better
another motivation is that quantile
regression gives us a direct way of
estimating utility function we want to
estimate a utility if we have
probabilities and outcomes we can more
accurately
guildy the expected utility function and
with that we can adjust our prediction
according to the customer preferences
another thing we can do with quantile
regression and we can try and fight
anomalies in our data let's say for
example if we have some sensor that
should be below 70 degrees with 95%
confident then if we see in our data
some some sensor that takes the value of
100 some observations we should be
suspicious about it observe about that
observation possibly moving it of our
data okay let's look at example of how
quantile prediction looks like on the
famous goggle house pricing dataset a
screenshot by the way is taken from the
spark beyond platform the the engine
does the whole data science process
end-to-end from data preparation to
feature search engineering modeling
evaluation and much more the leftmost
column is the real sale price of that
property the rightmost column is is a
random forest approximation of the mean
function and in between you can see a
various quantiles of the conditional
probability distribution for these
examples looking at this we can almost
right away talk about confidence
intervals let's see the first example if
you look only on the random first
prediction we can see that we are
actually overestimating this property
but having this column only we have no
indication for what's going to happen so
if we didn't know the real sale price
and we were
trusting this no indication for surprise
but taking all this information into
account we actually see that the real
sell price sits somewhere inside the the
interquartile range which is between the
0.25 and 0.75 quantiles so we actually
expect 50% of our prediction to fall
into this range so it's not so
surprising if I have all this
information I could get ready for this
situation no surprise let's dive a bit
deeper into the mat behind quanta
regression and to actually how we're
going to estimate the quantiles the
first approach will be a loss function
based optimization we want to optimize a
quantile regression loss a quantile
regression objective this objective
minimizes a sum that give us symmetric
penalties to over prediction errors and
under prediction errors okay let's think
for example about the 0.9 quantile the
quantile loss will take the form 0.9
times the under prediction errors plus
0.1 D over prediction errors yes we are
punishing the under prediction harder
than the over prediction okay so the
reason why we're doing it is because we
want to see other places of the
distribution so if we're punishing
isometrically we punish the under
prediction errors nine times harder than
the over prediction errors we are
pushing our no problem we are pushing
our prediction towards the right side of
the distribution and so our our
estimator will tend to overestimate we
are doing this for varios quantiles so
we can have the whole picture and okay
so the intuition that what we want to do
is we want to take our predictions to to
various places of the distribution to
get a better understanding of the whole
distribution let's assume on the same
quantal data were a quantile
approximation function takes the form of
some feature vector times some parameter
vectors beta the the loss function takes
the exactly the same form with the
quantile times D under prediction error
plus one minus the quantile times
over prediction errors hey now
approximating this function this
function is not differentiable
everywhere so you can use vanilla
gradient descent but smooth
approximation of this function does
exist on the literature and even one of
one such approximation you can find in
the gradient boosting in the
scikit-learn gradient boosting methods
all you need to do is specify the loss
function to be the quantile loss and to
choose what quantal you wanna model
another option is a bagging based
approach we want to further exploit a
bag of model to do this job the main
idea is to train the bag in a way that
will represent the full conditional
probability distribution of Y given X
and the main problem with this is what
we usually do we train on the same data
so so our predictors tend to be highly
correlated we want to break this
correlation and we do it by further
bootstrap sampling our data set and or
restricting our features let's look at
random forest based algorithm for
example for following this ideal we can
do one of the two option one instead of
retrieving what we usually do is we are
taking the mean the average over the
leaf we can retrieve all the observation
at leaf overall the bag then we can sort
it and treat it as is the full
distribution and derive whatever
quantiles we want another option is that
we expand the tree fully up until one
sample per leaf then retrieving the
whole bag if we have enough break two
predictors we can hope to approximate
the full conditional distribution and
from there it is straightforward to to
derive the cuantas now when using this
method one should remember that there is
a trade-off between the accuracy of the
predictors and their independence and we
actually control this trade-off with the
with the size of our bootstrap sampling
hey some empirical result we've tested
both the gradient boosting a quanta loss
and the trees distribution of just
described the the goal here is to
predict the 0.9 quantile so the
semantics for this prediction is
we are expecting 90% of our prediction
to overestimate okay and this is
actually what we measure here the y-axis
is the percentage of the percentage of
example overestimating the real value
and this this result seems promising on
both of the methods the triste
distribution seems a bit better on this
quiet extreme quantile achieving an
absolute error of less than 10% on 15 of
the 18 data sets this is quite
impressive because they you need a lot
of information to to be able to model
unique one tells another fast comparison
this is also comparing the two methods
that the x-axis or the zero point is the
gradient boosting performance on us that
we saw earlier and the y-axis is the
increase or decrease in performance the
triste distribution have over the
gradient boosting also here we don't see
a clear winner but but begging seems a
bit better at this extreme quantile okay
so to summarize we've seen the problem
of quantile regression and we understood
a bit what it can help us with respect
to standard min regression in two
approaches two possible approaches for
estimating this quantile we saw some
evaluation and during the way I was
trying to give you some possible
application like confidence interval
animal detection and others but you
should be able to think about many more
applications thank you questions
[Music]
maybe should consider the quanta
aggression is no is not magic if this
information if you can't find this
information based on your features if
you have a presentation is not good
enough you can't hope you to do very
good on other quantiles
so this model is we probably didn't have
very good representation feature-wise
for this model so we could not expect it
we didn't have a good approximation of
the mean function as well here so we
couldn't hope to have such a good
quantile approximation but it looks like
it is very low but 60% is not very low
because if you think about it the mean
approximation should be around the 50
it's not very bad but yes this is the
worst among them yes thank you
[Applause]
hi everyone
I tend excited to be here as always I'm
going to talk about background removal
with a little bit about myself my name
is Edie dance a machine learning
consultant and all kinds of projects for
a company's some time for doing my own
project and a product so I want to talk
about this product that I did with my
partner alone who is going to totally
after me which is the background removal
with deep learning so what is a
background removal we started the
project a few months ago and remember at
the beginning of September we released a
product
if you quit fingers you can go to this
site and try it maybe later with the
blog post and code and everything about
this project that we did it
why we did it and philosophy and sing
and sing the market made like if someone
likes peace with the community you can
read everything we have the coder how we
did it everything of course not all
projects not going to explain seeing the
picture what it is actually
our product is about all about taking a
selfie or is some kind of a portrait of
a person and then removing the
background what else you can do with it
whatever you like you can put another
background of why or the commercial use
cases are various first you can think of
is a green screen at the movie industry
all kinds of picture picture
manipulations industry is also very much
is not this by the way is not from our
product but a result sorry
close we will show you later so after we
define the task we then go into machine
learning to find the right to use so the
technique is a semantic segmentation
anyone here haven't heard of it and one
heard of it
okay so somatic segmentation is a really
famous task in in a deep learning
machine learning it's it has many many
projects many algorithms out there in
the github that you can use so we felt
pretty safe in doing mine this way
what is the semantic segmentation is
taking it's taking a picture and
segmenting it by the by its objects like
Otto cycle and the rider actually it's a
interesting problem because you need to
segment every pixel in the picture after
we define the problem and and the
algorithms we there are not many
datasets for this kind of problems
because it's really hard for people to
take a pixel by pixel so we're not as
many data set is in other problems many
data sets in this personal exhibition oh
one it's called canva then one is called
rock canva data set is is the top one
here it doesn't fit our problem because
it so but the cocoa is really as very
really various pictures like the
background so this is a good data set
that we chose after we chose the data
set we wanted to filter it there are
many pictures which may seem relevant
but they are not relevant
not really a portrait many nice this
picture oh so it's not good fit for
product the left one is good so we went
on filtering tasks and we left out from
a 100,000 pic chosen with only a little
bit about semantic segmentation
algorithm so many of you know about the
Albee plan in work so with the
interesting thing about semantic
segmentation a bit algorithms are really
familiar to the algorithms of image
classification let's see an example
schematic example I can't waving of a
classification algorithm we give him a
picture and to turn the cat so taking
the same algorithm and expanding the
last layer actually building it with
using it as a decoder can give you a
heat map of the picture and actually
segment the cat this is like one of the
early versions of the algorithm of the
algorithms but this is the main idea in
all the semantic segmentation algorithms
meaning we focused on two quite famous
models of we first tried to tried it
with the small amount of images really
quickly we saw that the tiramisu at the
better results and the unit like gave us
things that are really blobby so we went
on with the tiramisu about it so the
thing about this model that as I said
earlier it's really built from a picture
classification the dense net that's not
is a classification algorithm which a
really good
small mountain data and this one the
tiramisu is actually the same thing with
a decoder layer older layers but that's
the same thing as the classification
algorithm and how it works in high-level
whoever is interested after having the
algorithms the tests and everything the
dataset we find our metric which started
training and Retraining and doing all
kinds of things with the data set
emitters and sorry about the low quality
but you can see the idea that 88% i/o
you may be good for a few things but
here is like only 99 95% bring us to
results that we can release with our
examples from our from a product I must
say that we don't save safe data of
users who use the products all myself
without any examples so I looked at my
what's up with it and say that they
around the half of the pictures they
give good results like this and if you
try resort pictures like underwater or
something it so further progress how can
we further program only we'll talk about
the matting so the matting is another
problem which is not semantic
segmentation it's like something here a
bit a bit more focused like doing
semantic segmentation which is really
fine and and precise and this is a
problem which is don't my
we give orders it's much better open
severe like the rich as far as I know
the rich I don't know the exact numbers
but they differ any semantic
segmentation is much better like if I
come over another like maybe not a
question with small comics this is a
very specific case of segmentation where
a synthetic data can be very easy to
achieve in for increasing your tiny data
set to collect from Google that I was
not background created back home run
during ingest and increase your planning
suit is it something that you
indivisible yeah we did some experiment
but we had a we felt like we have enough
data we have ten thousands of images and
like running on one or two gpo's it's
like enough we haven't reached the
problem of when we need more more data
okay alone which is going to tack after
talk after me about the deployment here
I think everything video is a bit
different thing because it's a it's a
bit easier because you have the previous
image so if you use the previous image
you can like if something moves you can
segment it easier it's a correction
Weaver I'm doing a little bit of a
different talk than what we've seen up
until now as giddy talked we've been
thinking how to productize deep learning
solutions and as part of it we chose
this problem of background removal which
is fun we open sourced the code and the
model and the deployment everything is
open-source and is available on github
and you can see the server demo as well
as the client-side solution which was
implemented in case yes
for today I will only have time to
probably talk about the server-side
solution and just a quick introduction
my name is Alan Berg so somebody was
asking about the cavanna Cagle
competition we I reached rank of 28 and
currently we're doing a cdiscount Cagle
competition so if anybody is doing over
sampling right now please give us a call
afterwards I would like to stress how
nice it is that once you have something
working to be able to deploy it and see
real results in in in production
and that's why I'm going to talk about
serving with continuous integration the
tools with which we chose so at least
the background removal was trained using
and using a deep learning framework
that's called Kara's who's familiar with
Kara's maybe okay sweet so I wasn't sure
how many of you guys are deep learning
and the tools that we chose for serving
is flask which is a micro framework for
web development so basically you can
just take one one file and do the
serving and static HTML ins and we will
use git LFS
which I think I know not many aware of
of git LFS but it's an important tool if
you're trying to save in version control
your model and binaries and weights so
git LFS was released by github some time
ago and once you have this dis running
and tied up to the to your product it's
very nice to be able to commit your
weights and have like a one gig file
sitting version control well and being
deployed at the same time we will use
docker container confer containerization
and what toca allows us is to build
reproducible environments which can both
run on your production server and
development machine and we will use 0qu
for free serving I always like to to
note the the small notes so I wrote down
that if you into trying to serve your
stuff you might consider checking out
scale well which is a European server
company which really helps some cheap
offerings you can get a 20 for your
eight calls
32 gig of ram and 58 giga SSD and OVH
wizard which is currently our brief
server hosting you can get a 150 dollar
month dual GTX 10 16 which is really
nice and I should stress that it's
dedicated meaning it's not it's not
cloud that performance is super and then
finally we will use github CI which is
tying everything up so basically we can
just somebody can do a pull request for
the weights or do an improvement to the
model push the weights and it's all
being deployed and being served free so
I won't go over all the code and won't
bore you too much but just so you can
see this is open-source it's available
if anybody wants to do a pull request it
will be deployed automatically by just
one click and you can see that at the
top we are loading the model with Kara's
we are setting up a default session
since this is multi-threaded environment
so we need to take care of that since we
are doing background removal so you can
see the parts where we're taking the
image from the request we resizing it
predicting the semantic segmentation as
giddy was explaining meaning trying to
find out which pixels are actually the
people in there in the image and then
using those pixels that we found out too
to give the transparency layer and then
bring pushing it back to the response to
the HTTP response and at the bottom you
can see that just the homepage serving
which is a static HTML just digging deep
deeper into git LFS so if you're going
to install git LFS
use the instructions from the website
and you will have to doing to install
the hooks for get so that every time you
push changes to the binary files it's
actually not pushing directly to get its
uploading separately from from git git
has been no
to not handle nicely big files since its
it has this a cyclic graph and it's
computing the shy ones and you don't
find so that that every time somebody
clones the repository he will have to
download all the history of the models
that's why git LFS was invented so three
commands will get you going and then
finally docker I hope nobody will get
too bold
oh I know it because docker can
sometimes be a pain but the idea of
docker is that you can containerize your
environment you can set up the entire
three OS dependencies with just a few
lines in this example we're actually
taking we're starting from hero cumin
akanda image you can see the top line
we're installing the requirements and
then finally the last command is how we
actually running the web server so this
helps us actually run the same way as
production and also on my local laptop
and we use here aku which also supports
docker to deploy to deploy our model and
server so after we we have built this
docker image we we can provision every
rakah say well just one command here oku
is a platform as a service company that
abstracts all the devops operations so
you don't have to deal with memory
scaling databases and they have a nice
free tier and so finally to tie
everything up we can use git lab they
have nice offering for groups you can
just do private repos for groups free
and they have
simple continuous integration solution
in which you can just dump this simple
gitlab CI y ml file so for example
ideally who's familiar with continuous
integration mail maybe yeah so usually
it's continuous integration might be a
pain I just want to show you how it can
actually be easy and how satisfying it
is to be able for somebody to just that
might not be involved in the deployment
strategy or might even not have content
adventures for actually deploying the
the changes you can just push changes to
the code and with once you have it set
up it's it's working so the yam elf I
would go and define the stages so
ideally you would have something like
build a docker image test your server
test your code finally deploy to a
staging environment and then deploy to
production and that's the workflow that
I just discussed and you can see this is
available online you can all see the
history of deployment they log real time
once a new commit is being pushed the
the worker is spinning up and the build
is coming up and the entire thing is
available and this is really nice
everybody can fork it there's a docker
registry to see for history that's it I
want to tell you about
Yonatan Yonatan is my youngest son I
know that once he grows up and comes to
me help in math or in physics I'll
always be there for him
but if one day he asked me or poetry or
just sending back to his teacher or his
mom so the reason I'm sharing with you
my embarrassing parenthood it's
perience is that in many senses it's
similar to raising kids is similar to
raising machine learning models we don't
always have the information at the data
and the data and the knowledge is very
valuable so in some cases we need to get
help from external entities so when
we're talking about children it's
obvious that we send our children to
school but we never do that when when
raising when building machine learning
models we always do it in-house so I
have some experience with the algo
trading firms and my experience we've
done something similar to sharing
knowledge and teaching each other and
helping raising good machine learning
models what's special in Alba trading
firms is that it's very easy to
encapsulate the business model into one
small team a very small team has its own
expenses own revenues and it's very easy
to calculate how much does that team
contribute to the P&L of the whole firm
so in that case we have that team has
invested a lot in building its own data
so it has its own local data bank the
data bank is very expensive by getting
the raw data it needed to pay for the
world a tight clean the data and the
data is fed into some machine learning
or deep learning model data is labeled
or classified and
every such team has its own lost
function and using such a system the
machine learning some point it's it's
freezed out and deployed you know trade
in the exchange once it's deployed it
generates some orders and the orders
just hopefully they make money at the
end of day now the advantage of such a
system that everyone knows exactly what
they need to do what's the problem in
case there is a problem and the all of
the team is very focused to get the best
possible revenue the disadvantage here
is that they don't really help each
other the different teams every team's
each one of the team only helps its own
teammates and they can't help each other
because every team knows a lot and has a
lot of data that can help the other
teams so the solution we came up with is
a system that enables the different
teams to reward each other by teaching
each other so if I go back to children
and sometimes I send my my child to
school or to a private teacher so in
this case I have a trainee team that
puts up its model onto the system no one
can see the model no one can see the IP
behind the model but it that trainee
team ask the other teams to contribute
to it by feeding their data into the
model and teaching it so we have one
trainee team and several trainer teams
the trainer team feeds the data into the
machine learning
a with the labels and the trainee teams
need to put aside some of its data as a
hold out and test data at every every
sample or every batch of sample the
result of the holdouts data is written
into some holdout result certificates
and at the end of day all of the result
certificates are fed into some central
contract and according to that central
contract reward is paid to each one of
the training teams now the main problem
here is what's going on how do we
exactly reward each one of the teachers
in a fair way for example here we have
some example of a typical learning curve
curve and let's assume that one of the
teachers was responsible for each one of
these changes in the score for the model
being learned so in some cases the score
went up these are the green arrows in
the red arrows the score went down but
how exactly do I reward that specific
teacher was it a good one we need to
come up with some function that would
reward the different teachers in a way
that would be fair good teachers should
be reward better than bad ones we also
need the teachers to feel that they were
treated well I mean they need to know
exactly how was the reward calculated
and we also need to redefine how much do
I want to pay all of the teachers and
one other problem that we've met when
introducing such a system is that
because the entities are very separate
in each one of the trading teams it
looks only on his own benefit some
trading team tried to take advantage of
irrelevant issues for example if we know
that the learning curve looks like that
and I'm a teacher I'd like to teach the
system in that area because in that area
the gradients are higher there is some
momentum and even if my samples are not
that good I'll probably raise the
learning curve curve up so we need to
come up with the with a function that
would be unable to answer all of these
issues so one type of a function I want
to present here is the is that one in
that case for for having that function
we need to approximate how how
approximately does the learning curve
look like in such cases so learning
curves I can classify them to learn in
case like this one this one is more
sigmoid Ile I can classify learning
curves as some that would look more
linear some would look logarithmic so in
this case that's a sigmoidal learning
curve and in in our case we have a
teacher J that gave one sample and that
sample raised the score of the
out-of-sample data from s0 to s1 now if
I have the approximation of the learning
curve
I can just I need to flip the
approximated learning curves such that
the score would be on the x-axis and the
iterations would be on the y-axis so
here we need to flip and rotate it and
if we take the derivative of that
approximated learning curve we get the
function f here the function f has has
some meaning function f is actually the
amount of energy energy in terms of
iteration and samples that is needed to
be invested in our fitting model in
order to improve the score at each one
of these points so the actual reward for
that specific teacher would be the sum
of the improvements each one of its
samples contributed each one of these
samples in that equation is I and for
each one of the of the samples the
contribution is just the area beneath
the F function for the improvement that
that sample came now that's just an
equation that allows us to quantify the
the contribution beyond that in order
for the teachers not to be able to fool
the system we need to measure their
contribution only in big batches that's
something else that is learned from such
a system and in that way we we were able
to join several teams where each team
only looks at his own benefit and allow
them to somehow synergize each other and
bring the other to new levels of
of learning now I guess you are tired
and you don't want to ask question but
you can but if not my mail is here yeah
no no can't be rewarded negative you you
need to take out of the system ones that
didn't contribute and there is a way to
do it falsely that system is built in a
way that if someone puts trash data in
the system it hits it out and it still
allows the others to contribute continue
and that's just like trash dating okay
so even if it's negative it spits out
yeah but eventually it will pay itself
so you earnt nothing it's just like you
teaching you're your own kid and paying
yourself okay thank you
[Applause]